We’ve all battled traffic as we sludge our way
through a concrete sea on the way to work. This,
my friend, is the disheartening reality of urban
sprawl. The unbridled expansion of cities has
unleashed a slew of nasty consequences for people
and the planet alike. In fact, the UN predicts
68% of us will reside in cities by 2050. So is it
about time we reviewed how we build those cities?
As concrete jungles invade pristine wildernesses,
precious ecosystems are demolished, resulting in
dwindling biodiversity and the demise of countless
species. According to the World Wildlife Fund,
habitat loss is the primary peril
for 85% of all threatened species.
Also, cities demand ever more water,
energy, and raw materials to grow,
which is often correlated with higher
air, water, and soil pollution. Today,
urban air pollution is responsible for
around 240,000 premature deaths in the
EU every year. Although it’s interesting to
note that these figures have been falling
over the past decade, as many European
cities seek to reduce their emissions.
Urban sprawl also gifts us the
joy of lengthier commutes. We
forever find ourselves travelling
greater distances to work, school,
and elsewhere. This only fuels traffic congestion
and air pollution, tarnishing our overall quality
of life. The average American wastes
54 hours per year stuck in traffic.
Urban sprawl also threatens the little
green space that is left within most
cities. Oases like parks and gardens
bestow bountiful benefits upon city folk,
from mental health boosts to cleaner air and
opportunities for exercise. As cities bloat,
these precious places are often
gobbled up by new developments.
After WWI, skyscrapers were hailed as
the remedy to urban sprawl. They were
rapidly built far and wide, especially in America.
However, these towering giants aren’t without
their faults - they’re pricey to maintain,
and skyscrapers consume up to 70% more energy
per square meter than low-rise buildings.
Skyscrapers are, arguably, unsightly behemoths
that trade beauty for structural integrity and
maximal floor space. They also cast
long shadows, darkening city spaces,
and they create wind tunnel effects, making
adjacent streets unappealing for pedestrians.
Given these pitfalls, those pencil
fanatics we call architects have begun
exploring alternative solutions.
And some have sought inspiration
from the very depths of the Earth
itself. Enter the Earthscraper.
Earthscrapers turn the concept of skyscrapers
on its head - literally. Burrowing deep into the
ground, they create layers of subterranean spaces
for humans to do whatever weird things humans do.
It's probably dawned on you by
now that Earthscrapers aren't some
fresh-out-of-the-oven concept; it's merely
a snazzy term for a very ancient idea.
The Cappadocia region of Turkey, is home
to the underground city of Derinkuyu,
built around the 8th century
BC. Whole communities of up to
20,000 residents were carved into the pliable
volcanic rock, giving birth to a labyrinth
of homes, stables, wineries and chapels,
all nestled beneath the earth's surface.
But now, with new technologies, architects
and engineers can drill ever deeper into
the earth. Building subterranean
megastructures that would have
made your average resident of Derinkuyu
choke on his mead. As you can imagine,
digging as deep as the Empire State Building
is tall presents a myriad of unique challenges
that we must overcome. The biggest of which is
making sure it doesn’t collapse in on itself.
To ensure our little earthscaper
Sims don’t get buried alive,
good old reinforced concrete, famed
for its sturdiness and longevity,
will be widely employed. But engineers will also
dabble in cutting-edge reinforcement techniques,
like soil nailing and deep soil mixing - which
mechanically blends the existing soil with cement.
We’re also going to have to funnel plenty
of light down there to ensure a healthy and
pleasant living space. Architects
will employ light wells, mirrors,
and even fibre optic cables to send sunlight
into the structure's depths. Green spaces
and indoor gardens can be added to spruce up
the aesthetics and boost air quality. There’s
growing research that greenery is a crucial
ingredient for maintaining good mental health.
Energy efficiency will take centre stage
in Earthscraper designs. By tapping into
geothermal power with heat tubes,
these structures will capitalise on
the Earth's consistent temperatures
for heating and cooling purposes.
London Underground is an excellent example
of this technology in use - some above-ground
apartment buildings in London are now being
heated solely by the residual heat collected
from underground pipes that run through
London’s tube network. Moreover, water that
falls into the Earthscraper can be harvested and
recycled to decrease strain on urban utilities.
Speaking of water - you’re probably thinking, what
happens if it floods? After all, we’re essentially
putting a giant fucking bucket into the floor and
hoping it doesn’t fill with water. Fear not, there
will be gargantuan, advanced drainage systems to
quickly evacuate excess water. But it’s actually
groundwater seepage that poses a more significant
threat - that’s water from the surrounding soil
making its way in, like rising damp in your home.
For this, architects will implement watertight
concrete systems that have been tried and
tested for years in your average swimming pool.
We also shouldn’t ignore earthquakes.
Meticulous structural engineering will
be needed to ensure they endure seismic activity.
Solutions like base isolation systems and seismic
dampers have been effectively employed in many
existing buildings, notably across Japan, such
as the Tokyo Metropolitan Government Building.
One place that’s genuinely looking
to expand downwards is Mexico City,
a vast metropolis of almost 9 million people.
Here, traditional solutions have struggled
to keep up with the city's rapid growth.
Especially since the city has put strict
height restrictions on new buildings within the
historic centre, so skyscrapers aren’t an option.
Enter BNKR Arquitectura, an avant-garde
architectural firm with a revolutionary
proposal: a 300-meter-deep, inverted
pyramid-shaped Earthscraper, designed
to provide much-needed residential, commercial,
and cultural space in the heart of Mexico City.
The audacious venture aims to tunnel into the
earth right below the city's renowned central
square, the Zocalo. By only using the space
beneath the square, the Earthscraper preserves
the iconic plaza and offers a resourceful answer
to Mexico City's spatial predicament. The design
envisions a sequence of terraced levels plummeting
deep into the Earth, each accommodating a distinct
purpose, such as residential, office, retail,
museums, and various cultural amenities. In fact,
the suggested design spans a staggering 65
stories. This would be a huge boon to the
city’s usable space without adding a single inch
to its footprint on the surface of the Earth.
However, this concept is not without its hurdles.
Boasting an estimated price tag of $800 million,
the financial feasibility remains uncertain.
And concerns over impacting the historic city
centre have made the locals get
a bit itchy about the project.
Besides financial obstacles, there are numerous
engineering and logistical issues to overcome. As
mentioned earlier, earthquake resistance
is a crucial factor for Earthscrapers,
and Mexico is especially vulnerable, being
located near 5 tectonic plates. BNKR’s design
suggests using a flexible, lightweight
carbon-fibre-reinforced concrete shell,
which would supposedly shield
it from seismic vibrations
Even with these hurdles, BNKR Arquitectura's
Earthscraper concept remains an exciting and
novel approach to combating
urban sprawl, and I, for one,
think it would be pretty amazing to see it
come to fruition. And the idea has already
encouraged other architects to think
outside – or rather, beneath – the box.
Take, for example, Japan's Shimizu Corporation,
which has proposed an even more daring project
called the "Ocean Spiral", a vision of a
self-sustaining, underwater metropolis.
Truthfully, it seems unlikely that Mexico’s
earthscraper will happen in the near future,
if at all, but there are a few smaller
Earthscraper-esque projects you can actually visit
today. Such as Montreal's Underground City, also
known as RÉSO, a sprawling subterranean network
spanning over 20 miles. Containing a plethora of
commercial spaces, including shopping centres,
offices, hotels, museums, and public transit
hubs. The climate-controlled space makes it
a popular destination during the city's frosty
winters, and RÉSO has attracted around 500,000
daily visitors since its inception in
1962. Proving that Earthscrapers aren't
solely for addressing urban sprawl; they
can be a major tourist attraction too.
Skyscraper-mad New York has finally set its eyes
below ground too. The Lowline is an audacious
endeavour to morph a forsaken subterranean
trolley terminal into a lively public oasis.
This pint-sized earthscraper, would
be outfitted with cutting-edge tech
like solar collectors and fibre-optic cables,
funnelling sunlight into its depths. Sadly,
after a decade of planning, the project now
looks to be dead due to financial issues.
It isn’t just bowling alleys and boutiques
that earthscapers could accommodate. Numerous
industries, like agriculture, could reap
the rewards of subterranean solutions.
Imagine underground hydroponic farms that
collect and conserve water and offer a
precisely-controlled climate for year-round
cultivation. Data centres could exploit
Earthscrapers' innate insulation and geothermal
cooling capabilities, cutting down on costs.
And, if we do ever get to Mars we might utilise
earthscrapers to create underground habitats,
shielding us from harsh surface conditions
and cosmic radiation. You could argue
that building earthscrapers
here on Earth is a priority,
so we have time to test them out and perfect
the technology before we expand into the stars.
In 2017, a team of MIT students won
the international competition "Mars
City Design" with their "Redwood Forest"
proposal. It envisioned an interconnected
network of earthscrapers on Mars, with
numerous living spaces below ground,
each topped with a large transparent
dome full of lush vegetation.
So, as we ponder the particulars of the future
of urban living, let’s not gaze solely skywards,
but consider the potential lurking beneath our
feet. Because who knows? By trying something new,
we could reshape our cities for the better. Or,
at the very least, we can build our
own Zion before the machines take over.